[Music]
you're working hard to provide your
customers with the best customer
experience possible whether that's
through machine learning applications
chat bots or mobile messaging
at google cloud we want to make it as
easy as possible for you to adopt
virtual agents and bots
which need to be integrated with
enterprise system and processes
that's why apigee which is google
cloud's api management platform
has native capabilities to make it
easier and faster to get started with
conversational ai
the specific challenge we're tackling is
connecting conversational ai products
such as dialog flow
with your back-end systems especially
legacy systems
our goal is to make the deployment of
bots and virtual agents faster
giving your teams time back to focus on
innovation
and give your customers a stellar
customer experience with speedy replies
and orchestrated responses
let's talk about how apigee can do this
apogee is an intuitive platform for bot
designers and architects to incorporate
key business function and insights into
the workflow
it acts as an api fulfillment engine
essentially enabling dialogflow to talk
to your backend systems
it does this in three ways your it teams
can get your conversational ai
deployment up and running quickly while
still focusing on other modernization
efforts
your conversation architects don't need
to spend time integrating apis
they can focus on building great voice
experiences for your customers
and all your teams can build apis once
and reuse across different use cases
apigee has native policies available
within the ui that will make the api
fulfillment process even more turn key
these policies can parse dial up flow
requests set dialogflow responses
and validate parameters captured by
dialog flow
i built a simple flow and dialogflow cx
that allows someone to rent a car
the user has asked when and where they
want to pick up the car they pick a
specific car confirm some details and
their rental reservation is booked
let's run in the simulator and see how
it works
[Music]
hello
i'd like to rent a car
san jose california
no
june 13th 3 pm
june 15 9 a.m
yes that sounds good
let's go with the charger
yes
visa
four one two three four one two three
four
john smith
2930 pearl street boulder colorado 80301
80301
it was easy for me to rent a car with
this agent the conversation was natural
and the agent was responsive
you may have noticed a list of
parameters in the simulator dialog flow
allows you to store pieces of
information and parameters
some of these come from what the user
says and others are retrieved from
back-end services a big part of creating
a good conversational application
is integrating with back-end systems
diaflow lets you specify a web hook to
connect with back-end systems
for example i use the web hook in the
list vehicle step of my flow
when the conversation reaches this step
dialogflow will make a call to the
backend system that has car inventory
information
in this demo i used apigee to build a
set of apis for my agent
apigee lets you quickly build and manage
apis apogee has two new policies just
for working with dialogflow
if we look at the step where the agent
lists which cars are available
we can see that it uses the get vehicles
webhook in the search cars tag
let's look at the definition for that
web hook for the web hook url i provided
the url for the api i'm managing in
apigee
i also supplied a client key from apigee
that will be passed as an http header
this client key identifies application
and lets apigee control access to the
apis it manages
next let's look at how this api works in
apigee
in apigee i created an api proxy to
handle requests from dialog flow
i've configured a set of apigee policies
over here and i have a series of flows
that handle specific requests
the proxy endpoint preflow is called for
all requests
i also have four conditional flows that
will be called depending on which tag is
specified in the webhook fulfillment
setting
in the preflow there are three policies
the first checks the api key that is
passed in the header
if the key is missing or invalid and
unauthorized response is sent
otherwise the flow continues
next i remove the client key header
since it's no longer needed
the third policy is an instance of pars
dialog flow request
one of the new policies for working with
dialogflow in apigee messages sent from
dialogflow have a json payload that
contains the intent
session id parameters and more that are
sent with the web hook request
pars dialog flow request takes this
information and turns it into variables
that can be referenced in this apigee
flow
let's turn on the trace and see how it
works
if we look at the trace we can see all
the details of what happened in apigee
when the web hook was called
the request enters here a number of
policies are called
we'll notice here in the parse
dialogflow request that a whole bunch of
variables got created
and those were based on parameters that
were present in our session in dialog
flow
all of these will be available in the
apigee flow and can be used in different
policies
we set a condition to follow a
conditional flow based on the value of
the fulfillment tag
in this case the fulfillment tag was
equal to search cards and this was a
post request
so that particular flow was followed and
these steps were executed
let's look at the flow that manages the
booking of a reservation this flow calls
out to a cloud function
the cloud function requires
authentication the first two policies in
here make a call to the google cloud
identity management system
they send some credentials that i stored
in apigee's key value map
those credentials are exchanged for a
token that i can pass in a header to the
call to my cloud function
the next policy is the call to the cloud
function that will make a reservation
i send the token in several parameters
that were sent from dialog flow
the car description the start date the
end date and the location
apigee then makes a call to the
reservation service and reserves a car
the response is stored in a variable
called reserve results
the next policy is an extract variable
policy and it's used to retrieve the
reservation id
and the reservation total from the
response from the call to the
reservation system
next i use the set dialogflow response
policy to send the reservation id and
total back to dialogflow as parameters
dialogflow uses that information to
confirm the reservation with the
customer
using apigee to manage apis needed by
dialog flow allows a conversation
designer who's building things in
dialogflow
to focus on providing an excellent user
experience rather than worrying about
how to integrate with enterprise systems
it allows an api developer to quickly
build a set of experience apis
to support this application they can
hide away the complexities of the
back-end services
this won't be the last api we need to
build for this project or something else
that requires access to back-end
services
but establishing a standard pattern for
this will save us a lot of time in the
long run
apigee and the two new policies
specifically for dialogflow
make this easy to do now it's your turn
to try it out and get started by
following the links in the description
[Music]
below
you